🎵Brooo!🎵
🎵Brooo...  🎵
🎵Brooo...🎵
(Brofist!)
🎵When things are tough🎵
🎵And you've had enough🎵
🎵Who is there?🎵
🎵To curb your fear?🎵
🎵All bridges burned🎵
🎵Nowhere to turn🎵
🎵Who will come?🎵
🎵To cheer you on?🎵
🎵Never let go, go, go!🎵
🎵Never give up, up, up!🎵
🎵Never let go, never give up!🎵
🎵You can reach your end goal 🎵
🎵Never let go, go go!🎵
🎵Never give up, up, up!🎵
🎵Never let go, never give up!🎵
🎵You let go, you asshole!🎵
🎵Do you know how Pewdie says goodbye?🎵
(Brofist!)
🎵Close your hand, let's give this thing a try!🎵
🎵Everyone just wants to fist this guy!🎵
(Brofist!)
🎵Pewdiepie-ie, Pewdiepie-ie🎵
🎵Lost all you had🎵
🎵A good thing gone bad🎵
🎵All alone🎵
🎵In the unknown🎵
🎵Then in the mist🎵
🎵You see a fist🎵
🎵Then who knew?🎵
🎵The legend's true🎵
🎵Never let go, go, go!🎵
🎵Never give up, up, up!🎵
🎵Never let go, never give up!🎵
🎵You can reach your end goal🎵
🎵Never let go, go, go!🎵
🎵Never give up, up, up!🎵
🎵Never let go, never give up!🎵
🎵You let go, you asshole!🎵
🎵Do you know how Pewdie says goodbye?🎵
(Brofist!)
🎵Close your hand, let's give this thing a try!🎵
🎵Everyone just wants to fist this guy!🎵
(Brofist!)
🎵Pewdiepie-ie, Pewdiepie-ie.🎵
🎵Brooo!🎵
🎵Brooo...🎵
(Evil laugh)
🎵Broooooo!🎵
(Brofist)
🎵Brooo...🎵
🎵Brooo!🎵
(Evil laugh)
🎵Broooooo!🎵
🎵Brofist🎵
🎵Maybe you wanna quit🎵
🎵When things fail🎵
🎵But you can't just fail when things quit🎵
🎵Maybe you wanna quit🎵
🎵When things fail🎵
🎵But you can't just fail when things quit🎵
(Yeaaahhh!)
🎵Do you know how Pewdie says goodbye?🎵
(Brofist!)
🎵 Close your hand, let's give this thing a try!🎵
🎵Everyone just wants to fist this guy!🎵
(Brofist!)
🎵Pewdiepie-ie, Pewdiepie-ie🎵
🎵Brooo...🎵
🎵Brooo!🎵
(Hahaha!)
🎵Broooooo!🎵
(Brofist!)
🎵Brooo!🎵
🎵Brooo...🎵
(Hahaha!)
🎵Broooooo!🎵
(Brofist!)
- Pewds -
Hope you bros enjoyed this song!
Roomie, thank you so much for making it.
- Pewds -
Really awesome, he worked really hard on it, so make sure you check out his channel.
Also, iTunes links in the description.
- Pewds -
And as always...
- Pewds & Roomie -
...brofist.
Subscribe to ROOMIE! I'll See All You Bros In The Next Video "BROFIST"